hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and skincare nerd
and lover of vitamin c
today i'm doing a collaboration with
beck winter who is a melvin based
youtuber she does tons of product
reviews and
if you know me if you ask me for a
product recommendation
i usually don't have very many beck
tries out
all of the products and does really
in-depth reviews she's very
science-based as well
and so if you want product
recommendations she is a fantastic place
to go to so
check her out her links in the
description we also did another video on
our favorite vitamin c products which
you can find on her channel as well hi
everyone my name is beckwinter and i'm a
fellow skincare
nerd i love skincare i love testing it
out and i also like the science behind
skincare because i think it's important
to melt those two worlds together so
that you can make an informed decision
as to what products and ingredients are
right for you and your skin
so we both get a lot of questions on
vitamin c so we thought we'd get
together and
give you our answers so the first
question is can vitamin c be used in the
morning because i read you shouldn't use
it in your am routine
beck what do you say absolutely
i love vitamin c particularly ascorbic
acid because it's such a great
antioxidant
and it really will benefit an am routine
because of its antioxidant qualities
particularly when you pair it with a
really nice sunscreen
i completely agree vitamin c is
fantastic for protecting your skin
against uv
and that's actually where most of the
first studies on vitamin c and skin were
it was all about protecting your skin
against the sun and reducing the amount
of sunburn you got
so it's definitely fantastic for daytime
use the antioxidants are great for
soaking up any free radicals that tend
to form
so free radicals are substances that
have unpaired electrons
and they're really really reactive so if
they're in your skin they tend to react
with things like dna
things in your cells and that's part of
what causes your skin to age
so having that in your skin helps
protect against photo aging it protects
against regular aging as well so any
free radicals that
naturally form from things that your
body does great for morning and night
why does
l ascorbic acid irritate my skin so the
quick answer to that is
it's an acid acids are irritating um
acids are low ph
that means that they have lots of
hydrogen ions and these can just
um it's like an acid burn it's a
chemical burn it reacts with your skin
ascorbic acid also has to be at a low ph
otherwise it doesn't get into your skin
it's a very stubborn molecule to get
through your skin and into the living
layers where it can have a biological
effect so if it irritates your skin
maybe you could look at using lower
percentage product
or a higher ph product or just a gentler
formula and over on my channel where we
are sharing our favorite vitamin c
serums i do have one that is a low
percentage l-ascorbic acid serum i
believe it's five percent and it seems
to be pretty well tolerated
by those of you with really sensitive
skin it's also paired with cintella as
the attica so that might help to
buffer against any irritation that you
may experience but it seems to be really
well tolerated so definitely check that
one out if you do want to use l-ascorbic
acid does
price matter i see some vitamin c serums
that are so affordable and others that
are over the top expensive
does expensive equal better so beck
you've tried everything in every price
range what do you think
um honestly for me most of my favorites
are very affordable or they're kind of
mid-priced
i don't have too many that are really
expensive that i'm willing to pay a lot
of money for
in saying that i would like to try the
ce folic acid from
skinceuticals but that is so expensive
and i just
i cannot bring myself to commit to it
because i think to myself
if it's going to do the exact same thing
in terms of vitamin c it's going to help
to stimulate collagen production
provide antioxidants for the skin and
also help to fade hyperpigmentation
why would i spend more money on it when
i get the exact same results from more
affordable products
no that's a great answer
i have i have nothing to add can you mix
vitamin c with sunscreen
um just don't mix things with sunscreen
for sunscreen it's really important that
it forms
an even film on your skin um you don't
want to mix it with anything because
firstly you dilute the protection and
secondly you might end up not mixing it
thoroughly enough and so you end up with
some spots that have enough sunscreen
some spots that have no sunscreen
so yeah don't mix it with things
layering rather than mixing
with sunscreens when it comes to
sunscreen think of it as medicinal
and just don't don't mess with it my
vitamin c turns my hands yellow um so
the reason for that is vitamin c
l ascorbic acid it slowly degrades into
erythrulose
which is a sugar which works much like
dha and fake tan so it's just fake tan
it's not like it's staining
your skin forever it's not like it's
giving you more pigmentation
it is just a fake tan thing which reacts
with the top layers of your skin
and it makes it go a little bit darker
so to avoid this i mean if it's turning
your hands yellow then it's probably not
a massive issue so wash your hands
immediately afterwards with soap and
water
um if it's turning your skin yellow
though like your face
then it's probably a good idea to layer
an oil-based
product on top and try to limit that
oxidation
you won't be able to completely undo it
but also if you apply your vitamin c
all over your face then hopefully that
gives you more of a rosy glow rather
than patches of darker
um fake tan i like that tip
if you rub it everywhere then it looks
like you intentionally meant to do that
to your skin
make it even make it even yeah if your
vitamin c is acting as like free fake
tan
go with it which is better a dedicated
vitamin c serum and niacinamide serum or
one product that uses both
i think it really depends on the formula
because if it is a really well made
formula
you have yourself a really nice hybrid a
multi-faceted product where you're going
to benefit equally well from the
niacinamide and the vitamin c
but if it's a really poorly made formula
then you're not going to benefit really
from either one of the actives can you
use vitamin c with retinol
yes can you use vitamin c with acid yes
but
um you do risk the you do risk burning
your face off a bit
because they're all very irritating so
that is pretty much the only caveat i
have have you ever used
like vitamin c with retinol or acids
before i have but i tend to use vitamin
c's during the day
um as opposed to the night if i do want
to use the vitamin c in the night i tend
to make sure that
the ingredient pairings that i have are
not going to be very irritating for the
skin
so for example i wouldn't use a 30
l-ascorbic acid serum with a really
strong retinoid or acid
yeah maybe if you do want to use a
vitamin c with these
sorts of ingredients maybe look for one
of the derivatives
and then save your vitamin c your profit
l ascorbic acid for another night
thoughts on natural vitamin c serum well
firstly l ascorbic acid is natural
or nature identical i think having the
known percentage of the vitamin c
is really important and i mean with
vitamin c you generally want something
5 10 15 and with the extracts the
natural extracts which have vitamin c
they tend not to be included in very
high concentrations so i don't think you
get that
that quantity of vitamin c on the other
hand there is also the fact that with
natural plant extracts they do have a
mix of antioxidants in them
and that tends to be really good for
keeping other antioxidants stable so
vitamin c is notoriously unstable so
chucking in other antioxidants in there
like vitamin e and ferulic acid keeps a
stable so having the plant extract
sometimes might keep it a bit more
stable
which might be a consideration but i
would probably look for a natural
in like a natural serum that has both
the l-ascorpic acid at a known
concentration plus plant extracts in
that case rather than just relying on
the plant extract for the vitamin c
so my problem when it comes to natural
vitamin c is is the fact that
in terms of if you did a qualitative
analysis
and you looked at the amount of vitamin
c in
one batch of carrot seed oil for example
and another batch of carrot seed oil
there is really such great variation
between
the amount of vitamin c in both products
so
what results you get from one product
you may not be guaranteed to get in
another product
and again because the concentrations are
so low
will it actually help in terms of
hyperpigmentation
probably not yeah i agree i like knowing
the percentage
um of something like vitamin c is
vitamin c supposed to sting or itch the
ordinary
one in silicone feels gritty and itchy
so this formula is one of the anhydrous
formulas this is where you have
l ascorbic acid crystals in an oil base
and that oil base protects it from water
from oxygen from light and that stops it
from oxidizing as quickly and breaking
down and becoming useless
so with these ones the problem is
because it's not dissolved
that's why it feels gritty it's like
little tiny crystals depending on the
brand
they might be different sizes of tiny so
generally you want
as small crystals as possible because
it'll dissolve faster on your skin
and so you end up with more even vitamin
c you won't get hot spots the problem
with the itching
is probably the creation of those hot
spots this sort of formula
is probably one of the most irritating
types out there
if your skin is too irritated with these
silicone-based formulas i'd recommend
just looking for a completely different
type of product so maybe a water-based
serum
maybe one of the derivatives and avoid
this sort of
solid l-ascorbic acid formula i feel as
though the vitamin c products that are
housed in silicones
tend to have really high amounts of
vitamin c so
that's a lot of vitamin c for your skin
that can definitely add to the
irritation that you can experience as
well yeah it's a really good point about
the high percentages i don't think i've
seen one with a low percentage and
yeah if you have high percentage acid
it's going to be irritating yeah
is vitamin c really needed in a skincare
routine or can you get a serum that
includes it in lower doses
i feel as though we're going to have two
different answers right now because for
me
vitamin c is an absolute staple but i do
deal with hyperpigmentation that
constantly needs to be treated
and post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation
in particular is quite stubborn and
really hard to treat
so i'm always on top of that vitamin c
my answer would be
um it depends on what your skin needs
are so if you have
massive hyperpigmentation problems where
that's one of your very very top
concerns
like for back then yeah vitamin c is
fantastic
you probably want to include it every
day to get rid of existing
hyperpigmentation and get rid of
anything that's forming
um if it's not such a big problem if
you're mostly looking for the
antioxidant protection
if you're looking for um for creating
more collagen
then there's a lot of other ingredients
that can do that too and so you might
want to incorporate it at a lower
percentage so yeah um everyone's
different it really depends on what your
skin needs are and that is it
for questions so i hope you enjoyed this
video if you did you can click the like
click the subscribe um you can also
check out all of our other videos you
can check out my videos through my
channel you can check out beck's videos
through her channel which i've linked in
the description
our instagram handles are up here so
follow us if you want to find out more
about science-based skin care if you
have any extra questions
on vitamin c drop them in the comments
and we'll try to get to them
and yeah see you next time
you